this is the Jole underground podcast
number 80 with Echo Charles Emmy Jo link
Echo Charles sitting across from me
what's up EC what's up uh I want to
address something man and and sure this
is something we talk about and we're
going to talk about it
again one of the biggest problems that
you can have as a human
being is a lack of selfawareness
that is one of the biggest problems that
you can have as a human being and what's
crazy about it
is if let's say there's someone Fred
Fred has no
self-awareness if Fred sees something if
Fred sees someone else doing what he's
doing he immediately sees it's a
violation yeah 100% he's like oh W could
they be doing that he's thinking
violation mhm but when when Fred does it
himself that he doesn't see it he either
doesn't see it himself which means he's
to toally lacking self-awareness or he
doesn't think other people can see what
he's doing
M so you really truly have to learn to
detach and we talk about how to get that
done we talk about taking a step back we
talk about writing things
down we talk about ways to separate your
actions from your assessment of those
actions you you talk we talk about ways
to separate what you're doing and
pulling out so you can actually see what
you're doing and not be the one doing it
so you can like Fred when the time calls
for you can say oh I'm violating basic
principles right now I'm being dumb
yeah if you think right now if you're if
you're listening and you think like oh I
don't ever lose self-awareness this is
for you this is that's a that's a little
mind trick that's happening right where
you think you're always can see
everything that's when you actually
can't m
if you think if you think that no one
can ever see the moves that you're
making this is for
you this is for you if you think if
you're if right now you're like dude
joo's a little bit wrong man he's a
little bit wrong here I no one can see
these moves that I'm making no one can
tell that I'm taking care of myself
right now if you're thinking that right
now MH you're who I'm talking to
everyone can see it they can see it they
do see
it sometimes people can be so
unaware that they don't even consider
what other people are thinking they just
carry on like you see Fred he's just
doing what he's doing he can't even
comprehend that someone else could see
it it's not even part of the equation at
all it's not like hey they probably
don't see it or hey this is what I'm
doing and it's but they can't no they
they don't even recognize that that
could be a thing I've known people that
are
that lacking in self
awareness so you have to be on the watch
for that we have to be
careful uh think about what other people
are thinking right this is the this is
the dichotomy of like I don't care what
anybody else thinks which is in some
ways a really good attitude to have and
in some ways it's a really horrible
attitude to
have right some ways it's great to say
hey you know what I don't care what they
think also if you think that you act
like that you're probably being seen as
a by a bunch of people as someone that's
looking out for themselves as someone
that's an egomaniac as someone that they
don't want to hang around with like
that's what's happening
yeah so how are we going to
detach what you know I always talk about
writing as a tool for detachment because
when you write things down you are
physically detached you can see the
words on the page now but here's what I
want you to write down I want you to
write down your
intent when you're doing something when
you're going into a meeting what's your
intent
your true intent what is
it write that thing down yeah write that
thing down and now once you've written
it down imagine that you're walking into
this meeting and you have that intent
printed on your
forehead yep that's a good one you might
as well yeah you might as well because
if you go in there thinking that they're
not going to know your intent they're
going to now listen they might not know
your exact intent but as we say intent
has a smell and they're damn G sure
gonna smell it and they know it smells
bad they you put some perfume over it
right put some what's the cologne if
you're a dude right put the cologne or
the or the deodorant put that on you can
mop that on there yeah and people smell
that and they even still
say no when they put the the little pine
tree right in the taxi cab you get in
there man it still smells terrible like
it smells pine needles and whatever else
Funk not good Funk y so you can try and
cover it up but you can't so write down
what your intent is so you can detach
from it so you can see it and once you
see
it know this that intent that you have
it flows into how you car yourself it
flows into the way the words come out of
your
mouth it's part of
you it's truly part of you and you can't
cover it up and I've seen people that
think they can do this and
it's the lack of self-awareness is is
horrible you know it's like uh you see
someone that
has you ever heard a report from someone
that's um oh I have a great relationship
with that person and the other person
literally hates them yeah that's how
unaware they are I have a great
relationship with Fred Fred hates me
despises me and I think I have a great
relationship that's
that's how bad it
gets so you got to be
more suspect of yourself you got to be
more suspect of yourself you don't sound
as cool as you think you you do you
don't sound as slick as you think you do
by the way you really
don't right I talk about Merl Streep and
Robert dairo you're not Merl Streep
you're not Robert diro you're not acting
you're not fooling anybody you aren't
that good at acting doesn't
work
so if you sit down and you write down
your intent and your intent is
bad and if you if you would feel ashamed
to walk into the meeting with your
intent written on your
T-shirt hey my goal in this meeting is
to get is to look good in front of the
boss so I can get
promoted if that's how you if that's
what your intent is and listen everybody
knows it
if that's what your intent is you need
to do some soul searching and change
your intent your intent is bad your
intent is bad you should change your
intent to okay I am going
[Music]
to help with the mission I'm going to
put the team first that's my intent now
is where people get get messed up they
get jammed up jamed up is I think well
but I really want to get promoted okay
so you walk into that meeting with that
intent and guess what everyone can see
it no one wants to work with you your
boss thinks you're an ass kisser it's
all bad yeah if you're if you change
your intent you go you know what okay I
don't care about getting promoted what I
want to do is help the team put the team
first and and accomplish the mission
imagine you walk in with that on your
shirt and the other teammates go I put
the team first they see that they smell
it they go right on the boss smells oh
jao really cares about the team oh okay
he he really wants to get the mission
done okay they smell that now they get a
positive impression now they're like oh
we want to help the rest of the teams
like yeah we want to help you
too you know what you end up doing you
end up getting promoted that's a
byproduct yeah that's the byproduct of
what's going on so if your in write down
your intent do some soul searching don't
lie to yourself don't lie on that piece
of paper by the way this is kind of
piece of paper you better hide right cuz
you don't want you're freaking you know
someone rumaging through your office and
they say my intent for this meeting is
to get
promoted yeah watch out so write down
your intent and if your intent is not a
pure
positive selfless intent become a better
person become a better person and that
will absolutely help you it'll help your
team it'll help you accomplish the
Mission and it'll help you win so there
you go something to think about yeah we
we'll talk about like obvious little
things like name dropping and you know
like someone trying to one up somebody
whatever it's like this is all like I
used to have conversations with my
brother MH about this kind of stuff
where so he would start debates with
people oh yeah J Charles yeah and 100%
after a
while and let's face sometimes it's fun
you know depends on who you're hanging
around with but sometimes straight up
like some people don't want that some
people hey most people are cool with it
for half an
hour yeah more like 10 minutes but yeah
you make a good point but and yeah put
it this way the point is different
people like it to varying degrees right
some people but they don't like that
stuff right and after a while it's kind
of like hey you might rub people the
wrong way it's always trying to start
debating and wait but you're you know so
anyway we'd have these conversations
when we I talk to him about that kind of
stuff um and the way I put it which
actually you put it better but the way I
put it is what you're saying is correct
like the words that you're saying like
all your little points that you're
making that's all correct so what you're
saying is right but what you're doing is
wrong and he's like oh yeah and then I'm
like so why the heck because I'm sure
I've done it before too I'm sure like
you know we it's not like this rare
thing so I'm thinking why is that kind
of hard sometimes and
the in intent having a smell is a
perfect way to put it put it because it
doesn't have a look it doesn't have a
sound you know maybe some tones here and
there but you can more smell it than
anything yeah and even the words can be
the opposite of the smell but the smell
matters exactly right smell matters more
and that was part of my point when I
said what you're saying is literally
correct what you're saying but what
you're doing is wrong
so this is why it's hard this is why I
think anyway because you sometimes don't
even consciously you're not thinking of
your intent sometimes you are but
sometimes you're not the thing is it
doesn't matter but because you think
it's in your head they can't see it they
can't hear it all they can hear is your
words right so you think there's the
message there's the message they're
picking up on right stinks meanwhile it
stinks badly too and you know and so
yeah that and that's again that's like
the good way to put it where it's like
it it has a smell and but no matter what
you do no matter what how you cover it
up I like the cologne analogy too
because when you put cologne on that
stink it's just yet another stink smell
and it's actually worse because now they
they uh picked up on your original
intent and the fact that you're trying
to cover it up with some other like in
uh disingenuous stuff so I was like man
we got to keep keep that Under Wraps man
and I guess that's like an exercise
right like you got to kind of well
that's the exercise write it down yeah
that's the exercise and what's
interesting is like you said a lot of
times people don't even recognize that
they have an intent but you do it's
running in it's there's a decent chance
that it's running in the background like
the operating system is running in the
background for this meeting for this
life for this this job this family like
imagine you're going to talk to your
wife and you have your intent written on
your
head right yeah sure you see what I'm
saying y yep y yep and she's going to
smell that yeah and if it's not a good
intent she's going to know yeah your
kids same thing they're going to
know and they're also going to know if
you're doing something good they're also
going to know if if you're doing
something for the right reason yeah you
know you're work let's say somebody
you're working with somebody maybe they
they they have a relationship you know a
work relationship with someone else that
you don't get along with if you're like
well I'm going to sneak around and you
know try and make a maneuver everyone's
going to smell that yeah but if you're
just like hey man good to meet you yeah
you know hey good to meet you Fred hey
let's what can I do to support if that's
your intent truly but if you're like hey
Fred what can I do to support you and
they're know that oh you're just trying
to you know make a maneuver here no
don't let that happen clean your intent
be a good human this will help you this
will help you in the long run these
little conniving moves that you're
making are not going to help you in the
long run hey they might get you that one
promotion everyone hates
you right they might get you that one
promotions but they don't get you the
next one yeah you have to leave that
comp it's just a disaster like Jordan
Peterson talks about Psychopaths they
have to leave like they they have to
live in Detroit then they and these
aren't like I'm not talking about
Psychopaths that are murderers I'm just
talking about like the the non-
murdering Psychopaths people that are
just you know they're screwing people
over and they're and they have to leave
they can only do nine months in Detroit
and they got to go to Chicago for six
months then they go to Cincinnati they
just got they got to go from place to
place there's Burning Bridges everywhere
yeah so don't do
that there you go yeah that's going to
take some practice though cuz there are
some innocent situations like let's
say you want to debate with me no no no
no no I'm say you're CU I believe that
you were 100% correct I'm saying okay if
you keep it in mind you'll probably
understand that hey you might have to
really keep you have to put some effort
into this stuff sometimes because let's
say I make some coffee for my wife or
whatever oh no how about this let's say
I clean the living room or something you
know I clean it up nice cuz I know she
likes it clean but let's say she walks
by the living room she didn't even she
didn't even see MH you know I want her
to see the clean living room and be
happy you know but I still want that
credit too you
know so she walks by it right out the
door and I I'm very compelled to flag
her down and be like hey did you notice
the living room I cleaned up you know I
want that you know I want that praise or
credit orever aggressive with that like
you know what I mean yeah I've seen
situations where people are aggressive
about wanting that credit yeah oh yeah
by the way as soon as you're aggressive
about wanting the credit the credit is
worthless it's totally worthless like
when you're like hey babe didn't you see
I clean the living room she's like she's
mad like you just you went negative
right and and again on the innocent side
it's like I wouldn't approach it or put
it this way because as soon as you say
hey babe didn't you see I that's when
you wrote your intent on your T-shirt I
wanted credit exactly right but I
wouldn't are all like hey like mad I
would be like like in a good way but
still the intent is kind of but yeah
fully but the point is you really want
that like you want it so it'll come so
natural to be like wait a second look at
the living room you know or like you
know like you know at work you'd give
these examples all the time at work
where you know this project is turned in
and you did like literally half the work
right and you know you advise which
again takes practice but I I agree is
ideal to be like no no no you give the
credit to your team right even though
you did have to work or three quar
whatever but when you're new intent when
you say that even though you did have to
work see sometimes all of it but the the
um the compulsion to like want the
credit right especially to like a boss
that you really want him to like like
respect you and respect your work or
whatever it's strong and it's not even
necessarily evil or malicious you just
like I want to be represented accurately
in the in the results of this project
kind of a thing you know so it's like so
natural to be compelled to be like hey
but then just like I said once you jump
out there and start saying Hey I want
basically this is what you're doing what
you're saying is correct yeah sure eeko
you did half to work correct but what
you're doing jumping in the Limelight
and saying wait what about the my praise
cuz I want my praise too for me that's
what you're doing it's not correct yeah
it's not good whenever you try and that
when you have that feeling I mean we're
going this's a whole new rabbit hole to
go down yeah cuz now we're getting
resentful sure right once you get
resentful then you go C and Abel and
next thing you know you're killing your
brother because you didn't get the
credit that you wanted right what
happens yeah cuz your intent is bad
because when Cain made his sacrifice to
God yeah he did it cuz he wanted to look
good he didn't do it just as a pure
sacrifice like Abel did Abel's like hey
thank you God here's my sacrifice Kane
was like here's my sacrifice isn't it
like can I get a little can I get a
little head knot over here big G man
but no it was uh not enough if he wrote
his intent it would say I'm making
sacrifice to God so that I can be so I
can go into his light Abel said I'm
making a sacrifice to God because I want
to support him not about
me let me ask see
this this kind of has something to do
with it may me think of it so you know
bragging right yeah bragging and then
there's like humble bragging right which
is like kind of that right where it's
like like they're making anyway
so are there except like can you can you
brag about something is it ever like
kind of cool or fine for someone to brag
about something you think from an ideal
standpoint I I I think the answer is no
I mean I'm sure look we could parse the
world apart and find a place where it
makes
sense but I can't really think of one
man I can't think of one where that adds
gives you credit right I can't give you
I can't give you a situation where you
know what it's a
good that is a little excerpt of what we
are doing on the Joo underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jo underground.com And subscribe and
we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us strengthen
this Legion of Troopers that are in the
game with us so thank you it's Joo
underground.com it costs
$818 a month and if you can't afford to
support us we can still support you just
email assistance atjo underground.com
and we'll get you taken care of until
then we will see you mobile Ed
Underground